hello I'm Greg Sadler and I have a
request for you I'm looking for input
and suggestions about who it is that we
ought to add to the list of authors and
series for the worlds of speculative
fiction in 2024 now if you don't know
about the series it's been going on
since
2016 generally monthly and we have
produced over 70 different installations
of this and what I do is I take an
author a book series could be novels
could be short stories where there's a
common narrative universe and we talk
about some interesting philosophical
themes I do uh a video you can see the
the playlist for that and each year I
have have a number of authors already in
mind who I'll tell you about in just a
bit but I also try to get some input
from viewers fans subscribers anybody
who's interested in these sorts of
matters speculative fiction very broadly
includes fantasy horror sci-fi alternate
history utopian and dystopian literature
even superhero stuff we are primarily
interested in in books so we're not
talking about film or TV or Manga or
whatever else we're looking for writings
and I want you to give me your
suggestions remember it's got to be a
series so not just usually a single book
unless it's a really really long book
that has a rich world that we can
explore and has some philosophical
interest or depth to it so before you
give your suggestions you do want to
click the show more or video description
so you can see all the different ones
that we've done already I'll put those
in the video description and you want to
uh pay attention to the ones I'm about
to tell you that we're going to cover in
2024 because you know I'm sure you get
excited about that but we've already got
plans to do these nine so
we're going to begin the Year by uh
doing some more of Stephen Erikson's
Malazan stories we're going to focus on
his third and fourth book in that long
series memories of Ice House of chains
then in February I'm going to be looking
at two books by uh James Kennedy who's
written dare to know and most recently
Bride of the tornado I actually asked
him are these set in a shared universe
and he said yes they are so we're going
to do those then we have Jim Butcher
Dresden Files another long series we're
just going to do the first three books
Stormfront full moon and Grave Peril in
April uh Chelsea Quin yarboro the St
Germain cycle so we're getting into some
horror stuff with Hotel Transylvania the
palace and blood games in May we're
going to look at some books that I read
as a kid and they were part of what drew
me into the entire Dragon Riders of per
and mcaffrey if you're familiar with her
she has this series Dragon son Dragon
singer and dragon drums which are young
adults but I think could be quite good
so we're going to look at those and then
we're going to get much more ambitious
in June with Jeff vandermeir his
Southern reach Trilogy Annihilation
Authority and acceptance and then we're
going to go way back to some some uh Ry
stuff uh from the the 70s Michael morock
elri of melbon Mel melon rather uh
series starting with that very novel and
then sailor on the Seas of fate and the
weird of the white wolf another one
that's been suggested to me Tad Williams
memory sorrow and Thorn Trilogy we'll be
looking at next the dragon bone chair
Stone of farewell to Green Angel Tower
and then and in September we're going to
go back to Terry pret's disc world and
we're going to be looking at the novels
that Center on the character death now
that takes us up to September that means
that there's three slots open October
November December that's why I want your
suggestions so if you would if you're
cool with that put down one suggestion I
want just just one one per person
because what we're going to do is we're
going to look at which of them get the
most thumbs up and and if there's
duplicates of them so you know if
there's many people asking for author X
that will go into the hopper and the top
six are going to go on to a vote that
we'll do later on in this year and I'll
pick the top three in that vote to go
into Worlds of speculative fiction for
the coming year in the October November
and December slots there's a lot of
really great authors that I have come
across that way suggestions made by all
of you out there in you know out out
there in the The Ether participating
virtually uh stepen Erikson you know uh
prime example of that are Scott backer
all sorts of great fantasy worlds sci-fi
worlds uh Dan Simmons Hyperion cantos
are another great example so we've done
a lot of things uh take a look see who
we've already done think about who you
would love to see me cover this coming
year put it as a comment in the YouTube
video and within you know a few weeks
I'm going to tally all of them up and
we're going to have a deciding vote so
thanks in advance for participating in
this and you know hopefully this will
lead to some really great suggestions
coming from all of
you